All right, everybody here in theater 3 happening
now, secure, easy and performant VPC
resource connectivity with tail scale. Take
it away, Lee.
Thank you very much. Um, as
just mentioned, I'm here to talk to you about tail scale,
secure, easy,
and performant VPC resource connection. Activity
with tail scale.
Now, two words of warning, this is a sponsored presentation,
and I do work in sales, so if you feel
compelled to part ways with your hard earned
money as a result of this presentation, that means it's
gone well.
I think I can make a pretty compelling argument
for why you should do that anyway,
but let's talk a little bit about an agenda, um.
The pain of connecting to private VPC
resources, there are many, many ways to solve
this problem.
You likely have this problem already,
but you probably have experienced some pain
at some point here.
Uh, and I'm gonna talk about how Tailscale does things a little
bit differently. I'm gonna talk about the. Power
of wireguard which underpins tailscale's
connectivity solution.
I'm gonna talk about some use cases.
I'm gonna talk about how you can do it right
and how you can do it wrong,
and then you'll see that it says demo on here,
this is Las Vegas. I was out too late last night,
we're not getting a demo today.
So what does private VPC resource
access look like today?
Well,
what we have found, or what I have found prior
to being a solutions engineer, I was a
a system administrator, DevOps engineer, platform
engineer, whatever the title is this
week. Um, and what we generally found is
that actually connecting to things that are inside
your VPC that are in a private subnet
that are not exposed to the public internet
is fraught with complexity. If you want to connect
two VPCs together, you're immediately in VPC
peering pain or you have to deal with transit gateways.
You are. You have limited visibility
and control,
sure you can send all these things to cloudWatch and Cloud
trail, but does anybody ever actually look at
those things?
Um, the, the, the, the
costs of doing these things are immediately,
uh, painful, like, you know, AWBS
announced regional nat gateways, that's a, a
great change, but every single bite or every
single packet that goes through those gets
charged, and that's an expensive
operation. And then finally and most importantly,
I'd imagine everybody. Nobody here who's had any technology-based
background has used a VPN at some point in their lives,
and they've probably had to reboot their laptop
because the VPN has gone wonky
or caused you some level of frustration.
These are things that we hear about at Telscale all day.
Every single time we talk to a new company,
they have an existing connectivity solution
and they say the developer experience is
really, really poor, it's impacting
my productivity, it's making things really, really
painful.
The complexity can be kind of described a little
bit like this. This is a nice visualization
of a pretty
typical VPN or connectivity
topology. You might have some sort of VPN
hub and then you might have a gateway in another region
or a gateway in another VPC.
It's very limited to the network it works.
Model that you have originally ascribed
to, and if you have a problem
at some point in this path,
if a developer is trying to get into an RDS
database or a developer is trying to get to
something that's only an internal resource,
and they can't achieve that even though they're on the
VPN.
They don't have any idea how to
solve that problem, that's immediately an
IT ticket or it's somebody else
who's gonna have to solve that problem for them.
We hear all the time how painful and frustrating
that is and the topology here is a is a
an artifact of that.
So
A lot of these VPNs were built on
technology that was designed for a
day when your
work machine was under your
desk and was not a portable
machine. It had a cable plugged into it, so
you might be familiar with er VPN
technology with encryption that is TLS based and so
it uses certificate-based encryption.
A lot of the pain points
that you see in the complexity that we just talked about are
because of that lack of design for
modern networks. We.
Wi Fi now, we have laptops, we have cell
phones, you're on the move all the time. People
are working from coffee shops, they're working from
their homes, they're working from the office. Things are
moving around a lot more. And so
in the, in the mid 2010s,
uh, a gentleman called Jason Donnenfeld
felt so empowered to, to fix
this problem that he designed a new connectivity
solution called Wireguard. If you're familiar
with it, it was built from the ground up from our modern
networks. It has fewer bottlenecks,
um, which means you. You can connect all of the devices
in a network together. Um,
it's way more lightweight and predictable,
um, so it's a much more smaller boat codebase.
It was written from the ground up, um, it
has an entirely new cryptography stack underneath
it, and it is really, really
good in situations when you're moving around
a lot. It self heals the connectivity path.
So I can close my laptop and open
it again and my VPN is not
gonna go all, all sideways and force
me to reboot the machine.
That. That was one of the reasons
that why a guide was was was designed.
And we at Tailscale have built
our products on top of that technology.
So we are the easiest way
for you to get all of the benefits of this new
built cryptography and this new
built connectivity solution
without having to do things like key management, without
having to do identity, without having to
figure out how you're gonna build a client that works.
Telscale is a very, very straightforward way to
get to get all of those benefits.
We, as we said, we built it on on Wireguard.
We embedded identity
directly into the product, so we are SSO
driven. We don't charge extra for SSO
it's all based right from the, it's all
um required for you to actually sign up
for the product.
No usernames and passwords, none of that
kind of like legacy
security stuff. It works on any operating
system, any device, in any location.
So one of our engineers recently compiled
tail scale for an old um
operating system.
We work on your cell phone, we work on
your laptop, we work on
vehicle entertainment. Systems, we work on,
you know, we have tailscale deployed in submarines,
we have tailscale deployed in farms, there's tailscale
about to get launched into space, we will work basically
anywhere. And one of the, my favorite, um,
piece pieces of tailscale is that we actually
handle navigating out of your network
for you. So you don't need to open any ports,
you don't need to open any security groups.
It will, it will
connect these two devices together via
the magic of our natroversial.
And so
when we layer the identity on top of that,
you, instead of the other topology that we looked
at earlier, you end up with something that looks a little
bit like this.
Every device is aware of every other device in the
network, every device can communicate with every other
device in the network.
We have embedded the identity of
that device into the client,
and so then we decide
what you're actually allowed to communicate with
based on. Who you are and
who you've logged in as. And so we build this huge
mesh of nodes, and then we build an ACL
system on top of that, which will allow
you to be able to determine, you
know, can this person access this RDS
database? Is this person able to
access this EC2 instance? And so
rather than thinking about this from a network level segmentation,
we think about it from an identity-based segmentation.
What sort of things does this open up for you? Well.
I've used the term VPN
quite a lot already in the
6 or 7 minutes of this presentation,
but what we are finding from our customers
is that,
This can solve a whole bunch of things
that traditional VPNs or traditional connectivity
solutions cannot solve for you. So we've talked
a little bit about a standard kind of business
VPN use case. You have
employees that are on the road, working remotely,
they need to get access to internal
applications that you need to secure,
um, and we can solve that problem very, very straightforwardly.
We can also. Solve some more AWS
and like what we call machine to machine
based use cases. So if you look at
the the concept of CICD if you're
using GitHub and GitHub's manage runners,
you might wanna run a database migration.
But the GitHub managed runner is outside of your
security boundary.
Because Tailscale is so lightweight and small, you
can drop tailscale into a GitHub action
workflow.
Uh, we have a GitHub action workflow that will do set
up tail scale and connect you to CICD pipeline,
and you can now run those,
you know, RDS migrations or talk
to your EKS cluster that has an internal
API
really, really easily with just a single
step in a workflow.
And it's, it's a really straightforward way
of kind of enabling connectivity to
things that you couldn't previously do.
Um, you look at things like workload connectivity.
I don't know about you, but I, I've certainly
run, you know, some of the agentic AI
based things that are running amok around,
um, my laptop. I'm able to delete
random files and do whatever it wants. The
workload connectivity, um, and the securing
AI tenants of our platform
allow you to actually secure those things and stop
those things running rampant, um, and doing
things that you, you know, really don't
want them to do.
Workload connectivity is really interesting because previously
the way you would solve this, I know there were some announcements
today about cross-cloud um
connectivity for like
Google Cloud and AWS. We have
large organizations right now
solving that exact problem with Tailscale. They just
dropped two tailscales.
Agents, one in Google Cloud,
one in AWS, so they drop, um, you
know, uh, something in their ADBS VPC and
something in their data center or in their office,
and that immediately connects those two things together. There's
no configuration,
no firewall changes, no setup,
it just works straight away.
Um,
the other two I think are Edge and IOT,
um, because Tailscale is so small and lightweight,
if you are,
you know, deploying things like kiosks to,
um,
to different stores, or if
you are deploying, you know, robots
and, and all that kind of stuff, you can actually
install tailscale directly on those things which
will help you with things like getting telemetry
off them. Or debugging debugging
problems in those environments,
you know, it costs millions of dollars for
organizations to send technicians out to fix
things that are in the field.
You can install tailscale on those devices
and fix them remotely without having to get people
on the road. It saves you millions.
It can save you millions of dollars. We have customers saving
millions of dollars on Edge and IoT.
And then finally,
Our go to market motion is that you are gonna
love our product so much
that you want to take it to work. And
so I'll talk a little bit later in the presentation about
our pricing structure,
but our um default
setting is that you use Tailscale for your home lab.
We offer very generous, uh, a very
generous personal tier. So if you have video
cameras at home or you wanna check the contents
on your smart fridge and you wanna do all that remotely,
Tailscale is a free and easy
way to solve that problem.
So we talked about some of the real world problems here.
Developer access to resources in AWS is
the kind of straightforward one. You have EC2 instances,
you wanna debug why that uh EKS pod
didn't start properly, so you wanna get to EKS
worker mode,
you wanna get into a database to fix
a production issue,
you, you know, want to, um,
Get access to anything that is only confined
to the VPC.
Telscale can solve that quickly and easily
and straightforwardly.
If you want to connect two ABS regions together
or two ADS organizations together,
or perhaps you want to enable your customers
to be able to communicate back to your infrastructure
in a secure way,
Telscale can solve that problem for you.
We can help you with secure automation
problems. We can help you
things like, like I already mentioned, like GitHub actions
or Terraform Cloud or Jenkins runners
that need to actually communicate from
outside your security boundary to inside
your security boundary. And then as I already talked
about the hybrid and cross cloud connectivity,
um problem. I know there were some some announcements
today as I already said, but we've been solving that problem
for nearly 5 years. And I think we know what
we're, I think we've done a pretty good job of that.
That's er that's er the same slide twice,
er apologies for that. um,
so what does doing it wrong look like? Well,
If you have too many layers of indirection,
I already talked about this earlier in the presentation.
If you do too many layers of indirection, if you have
too many hops through an infrastructure
in order to make these things work,
the debugging and the user experience
is really, really painful. Um,
so each time you build some sort of
like hub and spoke connectivity model,
each one of those instances is a point
of failure that can cause you
problems. In really critical
situations. In a mesh-based approach, there
is no single point of failure.
No single instance can
can can break any of your connectivity
workflows.
We see a lot of organizations doing
what we call security,
security by IP address.
So you might be using things like IP whitelisting.
You might be doing things like only
allowing access from. Certain subnets
to other subnets.
I've seen in my career
hundreds of security groups that only allow
access on port and protocol,
uh, on specific IP addresses.
The problem that you run into with that is what if the IP
addresses change?
What if, you know, things move around and you
have to migrate these things? You know, that causes
real world connectivity problems and so we
focused on doing this via identity
rather than. Via
any networking level. So we wanna know who you
are, we wanna know the origin of the request,
and then we allow access based on that identity
rather than the IP address.
And then finally, I've talked about this a lot, but I really think it's
worth driving home.
The developer experience debt of doing
these things wrong,
sorry, of, of doing the things, these things, um,
right, um, is, is just
a, an experience that just works. It's
just way better.
So what does that look like for
organizations that have actually adopted Tailscale? Well,
Cribble
has grown their organization. You can see their
huge booth over there in the corner.
They've been using Tailscale since the very inception of the
company. They've grown
by 25x in terms of their employee
count, and they've had seen
no, they have. No dedicated IT resources
to actually manage connectivity. And
they attest a huge portion of that
to tailscale. Um,
hugging face, um, estimated
that they save 240 hours
annually just on provisioning
new users when they are onboarded
into the organization.
Um.
Call light, 1000 hours saved annually with
fewer VP VPN connectivity
issues. 90% reduction
in internal support requests from Instacart.
I was, um, you know, part of the, um,
the sales team that that was rolling out Instacart,
and the level of of happiness
that they got
just from switching from one product to another,
just in terms of IT tickets and like
people picking up the phone saying, hey, I've got a meeting in
10 minutes and the VPN's not working,
like. It, it, it made a
huge difference to their business.
And then in terms of actual like,
like real technology performance,
because we use Wireguard as our underlying encryption,
we've seen we can guarantee a 4x
reduction in latency because we're going directly
between those resources and 22
22X increase in 3. Though.
Um, we can often find that with tailscale
we can saturate,
um, the nick inside these EC2
instances
to,
you know, up to the 10 gig nicks basically. So you can
get full, fully encrypted connectivity,
um, like full,
a full throughput for
most EC2 instances.
So here are some diagrams that show you what that looks like in the
real world.
So here you can see we have an EC2
instance in a private subnet.
We have the Nat gateway in a public
subnet. You'll notice I haven't opened any ports
in this particular example. I don't
open any security groups. I only
need outbound connectivity. I do not need any
inbound connectivity.
Uh, and Telscope can connect me to my laptop,
I can run SSH commands, I can run
debugging things, all those kind of things. If you're
regularly SSHing into things or
using something like ADBS SSM,
there are a lot of things that are fraught with peril there. The
fact that you don't have to open any any firewall ports
is gonna make your security team very happy, I suspect.
Um,
we have a, um, a Kubernetes
operator so we can run within,
uh, EKS.
Uh, we can make, we can help you,
um, move your EKS control plane.
Obviously the default setting is public access.
Your EKS control plane, if there's a Kubernete zero
day tomorrow, a lot of EKS clusters
are gonna be in a really bad way. Uh, they're gonna
be publicly accessible.
You probably don't wanna put your MySQL database on
the public internet. I don't wanna put my EKS
control plane on the on the public internet. That's a very powerful
API
and tailscale will enable you to actually move
that into a private subnet, so you no
longer need to worry about that being on
the public internet. And I can do, I get the same
level of throughput and connectivity using the Tailscale Kubernetes
operator. Um, I can also use
telscale to connect,
um, EKS nodes using EKS
hybrid nodes. Um, so if you have
remote GPUs that you want to connect from
another cloud, and connect them back to your EKS
control plane, Tailscale can solve that
problem with you. Requiring no dedicated
hardware,
no, um, no capex in terms
of like spend,
you don't need EPSEC tunnels anymore. All you need to do is
install tail scale on the on the node that you want
to connect and everything will just work. There's a great blog
post on the on the on the AWS,
um, blog about how to do that.
Um, if you want to do, as I already mentioned, like
just connecting to things like, uh, uh, Amazon RDS,
very common thing. I imagine most people don't want
to put their RDS databases on the public internet
anymore. Um, so you know, how do you
actually run things like database migrations, how do you do
debugging? Uh, all you have to do
is run, uh, a tailscale
EC2 instance.
You create something called a subnet router
that advertises the address of the RDS
database and you can use that to proxy requests through
there. We see that as a very, very common use case.
And then finally, um, you know, if you
want to connect two
specific VPCs together,
obviously you can use transit gateways.
Very, very expensive, you can use VPC once it
gets to more than two connections, it
can be quite complicated and difficult to set
up. Um, you can actually connect
these two VPCs together with just 2
EC2 instances or 1
EC2 instance in each one of the VPCs,
and it will connect you together really, really easily.
I mentioned at the beginning, um, I
believe we have a plan that's right for everybody, um,
and one of the things that you could do
right after, um, this presentation
is go to Telscale.com and sign up
for our personal tier which is free forever,
up to 3 users, and 100
devices. I think that's a very, very generous tier,
uh, and again, our entire. Model here is
we want you to love tail scale so much
that you take it to work and replace that thing that's
been annoying you for years and years and years.
And so you can sign up right now if you head over
to our booth, um, it's booth 1818
over in the corner over there somewhere. We actually have
a code as well that will give you like 3 months
of our starter tier, uh, for for for
free as well.
So
that was just about timed perfectly right, I've got about
1 minute left.
Uh, I really appreciate everybody taking the time to join me
today. I appreciate everybody listening to me. Uh, and
I hope everybody has a great rest of the conference and thank you very much.
I will be over at the booth for the next 10 to 15
minutes. If anybody has any questions, I can probably take some
questions here as well, but thank you everybody.